huh suck it in I'm not sucking here
Selena Gomez slams her body shamers in
the best way I'm very honest though in
general cell is quickly becoming the
queen of relatable tick tocks and she's
a total mood while addressing anyone who
comments on her figure oh suck it in
I'm not sucking [ __ ] why real stomachs
is coming back okay we hear you loud and
clear Selena the singer appears to be
enjoying her hot girl vacation posting a
series of videos and sexy swimsuits from
what looks like her trip to Italy
Selena's one request she's asking the
haters to leave her alone
what part of my face says talk to me
yeah none
absolutely none
as usual
for Selena
everybody enjoys it keep the candid
confessions coming on Tick Tock Selena
we know it's your favorite place to post
first off I think it's so much more easy
glowing
um kinder community on Tick Tock and
fans love when Selena keeps it real
online we really got a kick out of this
hilarious slip up about her dating life
so how did you end it with that guy
I'll tell you in a second
yeah after Selena's Nana interrupted Her
filming a makeup routine for that
personal question the singer just
laughed it off and captioned the clip I
have no words while we don't know who
Selena had a fling with or split from
the singer hasn't been quiet about the
struggles of being single so I just want
to put it out in the universe that I'm
manifesting love and I would like to say
that I'm looking for my soulmate but at
this point I will take anyone in the
meantime Selena deserves a break from
her mini projects only murders in the
building is currently airing
oh my God what
Selena plus Chef is coming back for
season four soon new mouth-watering
recipes masterful Chef said a few funny
mishaps along the way and it was just
announced she's working on a working
girl reboot so yes Celine is proving you
can be 30 flirty and thriving
I don't really talk on Tick Tock so this
is weird
I wanted to say thank you so much to
every person that wished me a happy
birthday cell took a moment outside of
her normal funny Tick Tock videos to
personally thank salinators for the love
on her recent Milestone birthday
I'm 30
and um I'm so far enjoying it
[Music]